and minimalists hello everybody welcome
to the minimalist podcast where we
discuss what it means to live a
meaningful life with less my name is
Joshua Fields Milburn I am Ryan
Nicodemus and together we are the
minimalist welcome to episode 146 today
we're gonna talk about curation
generations yeah I love I love a good
curation now right I saw someone on our
YouTube comments last week why don't you
look at YouTube comments because it's a
great way to interact with with our
audience I mean I'm one of us has to I'm
hitting and so I found that where was
our YouTube comments are overwhelmingly
like helpful and engaging Noah by a
larger audience is pretty awesome and
linked or not
not too many trolls yeah but there was
one I like could you please keep it more
minimal with the time of your podcast
cuz and so I what I did whole I mean I I
wanted to listen to this person I
thought it was valid feedback so what I
did is I created two special podcasts
for them oh there's a secret I got a
secret
weekly two minute podcast for them now
Wow and so here's how it works here's
how you access the secret weekly 2
minute podcast if you want the
two-minute version of this here's how
you find it and it's a secret but we're
gonna share with our audience right now
okay share the secret all right step one
there's two steps to step one yeah is
you you go to our normal podcast on
YouTube yeah at the zero minute mark you
press play right uh-huh and I like where
this is going and then step two so then
it you're playing it's playing and it's
the podcast is going yeah that you're
right you're right this happens watching
but you haven't unlocked the 2 minute
podcast you're still at the normal
podcast how do you unlock the 2 minute
podcast step 2 at exactly the 2 minute
mark you press stop and you walk away
from your computer man that's crazy
voila that's crazy you now have a 2
minute podcast oh and here's the other
one so this is that one with secret I
also have a top secret 0 minute podcast
every week here's how here's how you
access that you unsubscribe from our pod
Cass oh my god I I didn't think we were
gonna start out patronizing our audience
no no audience just this one person oh
okay okay yeah yeah so yeah if you want
to learn to be more minimal you just
unsubscribe what anyone says when
because how many jokes do we hear dude
like I'm in the grocery store and I've
got like you know a half a dozen lemons
and someone come out to be like that's
not a very minimal amount of lemons like
as soon as someone inserts the word
minimal leg I assume they're making a
joke uh-huh and if they're not making a
joke I just assumed they're being a dick
Yeah right and I think people were
trying to like what's the term nagging
nagging or negging those are two
different things
okay both of which are not helpful yes
but I was at the the Bozeman Airport
last month and this guy came up to me
and I had my packed bag with me yeah
Katie act bag it was packed as well my
packed packed bag and and he was like
hey you're the middlemost guy is it sure
are traveling with a lot for a
minimalist I would turn around and walk
I wouldn't even have said anything
I'd have been late I just turn around
walked away I said I said oh that's the
first time I've heard that joke that's
kind of escalating the situation by oh
that is good that's oh man like I was
being a dick I'm sorry right yeah and
I'm glad you just have some follow-up
from last week last week you and I were
talking about perspectives and and last
night I was walking around preparing for
the podcast and this woman comes up to
me with this was like a foreign accent
and she goes actually I wrote down
exactly what she said here she goes can
I take a picture and I'm like the accent
was I don't know where is she from
Jersey
where she was I think Italian okay and
she can I take a picture and I'm like
yeah that's definitely Jersey and I was
like sure and so like she hands me her
phone and stuff arm around there I
started taking the fish yes no not just
just a picture of me yeah that's awesome
she had no idea who I was but like that
is all that happens you just assumed
yeah I mean cuz here's what happened we
developed these patterns over time like
yeah there was a time a decade ago for
sure even five years ago someone comes
up to me and says can you take a picture
I'm gonna just take their phone and take
a picture of them because no one would
want to possibly want a picture of me
but over the last three four years like
people come up pretty regularly to me
especially since I'm very recognizable
because I have a gigantic forehead
shoutout to our YouTube audience yeah
and you know people come up say can I
take a picture with you it happens very
regular sometimes they don't even ask
that's happened twice to me yeah someone
puts their arm around me like those the
selfie I'm like what the hell are you
doing like you could at least ask to
take a picture with me and so we we
developed these patterns we developed
these grooves and and so I had to step
back for a second like oh yeah you idiot
like this person doesn't want a picture
with you like we I'm just in this
pattern all of a sudden and and so I
need to step back even in moments like
that and say hey is this what someone is
actually asking me yeah yeah did it I
I'm so glad I have Mariah in my life
because she really helps me with
perception meaning like some like even
with movies like I just don't comprehend
like normal people comprehend when it's
putting together a linear story of a
movie I am constantly like alright so
who's this person yeah what do they do
can we rewind it have you seen Westworld
oh yeah I've seen a couple episodes yeah
I just backs and I finished season two
finally I know it's been out for a while
but we take our art time with it and it
is a what's
the phrase a a podcast Shawn will
probably know it's like a anyway it's
definitely nonlinear but but it's a
puzzle right it's a puzzle box puzzle
box narrative is the way to describe it
and so there are certain parts that
start in like roughly 1952 and then
parts that are in 2015 and you don't
really know when until the very end it's
one of those things that like Infinite
Jest is another example the book Anthony
Jess yeah the first chapter you have to
go back and read after you finish the
book cause you realize that the first
chapter takes place after the end of the
book and-and-and but Westworld was even
more so like you're you have all these
puzzle pieces and you and especially
because some of the actors play two
different characters in the story it's
highly confusing it makes me want to go
back and re-watch the entire thing like
spend the weekend and and just like I
don't know then three or gameofthrones
men like it I've never seen because I
can't commit to something like that yeah
there are so many well it's as long as
long as like Breaking Bad I mean it's
but it's probably it's not your style
because it's got dragons and n stuff man
yeah I mean it's not nearly it's not
nearly boring enough for your taste it's
got way too much excitement putting too
much fun plus I'm super prejudiced
against dragons we just lost our dragon
audience Josh hey
they're probably listen to the two
minute podcast anyway I think we're past
the two minute mark at this point so
we're talking about curation today and
and I think one way to describe
minimalism is minimalism is a well
curated life yeah I wanted to talk to
you because I don't like just finding
articles that back up my points but I
sent you this article this week about
this one this one's from Bloomberg it's
an op-ed piece by Tyler Cohen and it's
called American zone less stuff and
that's reason to be nervous first off I
totally disagree and I think most data
will actually back up that we don't own
less stuff what
means is we have access to more things
like Kindle books as opposed a physical
book we have less of a need for
ownership less of a need for ownership
of physical item rights like no longer
do I need a cassette right when I can I
can have the album in my pocket or
medieval exactly yeah so let's read this
and let's let's try to talk talk about
it and we'll pick it apart a little bit
because I think this applies to the
topic of curation and how we can have a
well curated life I think some of it has
to do with access so here's a Tyler
Cohen says some social problems are
blatantly obvious in daily life while
others are longer-term more corrosive
and perhaps mostly invisible lately I've
been worrying about a problem of the
latter kind the erosion of personal
ownership and what that will mean for
our loyalties of traditional American
concepts of capitalism and private
property the main culprits for the
change are software and the internet for
instance Amazon's Kindle and other
methods of online reading have
revolutionized how Americans consume
text 15 years ago people typically owned
the books and magazines they were
reading much less so now if you look at
the fine print it turns out that you do
not own the books on your Kindle
amazon.com Inc does and and my response
to that is so what like yeah that's like
it's like iTunes music I mean we spend
10 bucks a month we don't own the music
like if we ever cancel that subscription
we lose the albums that we downloaded
right yeah it's but it yeah but so so
think about like you and I used to get
like GQ magazine in the mail right and
you're in my basement I had like big
bins full of old gqueues I had ownership
of them yeah but the value isn't in the
ownership of the artifact to me the
value is in the words themselves if
you're getting value from the book you
can evaluate from the magazine or
article you can value from the music
it's not because you own that CD it's
because you enjoy listening to that and
I am I've become vehicle agnostic I
don't care whether it's on a CD
I own one CD it's parlor Hawk second
album parlour Hawk and it's in my car
like I cuz my car has one CD slot and so
is that not on strength the streaming
platforms or it may not be I know I have
a downloaded version of it but andrew is
the one who did the soundtrack to the
lead singer of our of our of that band
did the soundtrack to our first
documentary and the good news is they're
gonna start working on the we'll talk
about this later but yeah they're
working on the soundtrack for the second
documentary anyway back to the article
here I do not consider this much of a
practical problem yeah yeah me either
although Amazon could obliterate the
books on my Kindle this has happened
only in a very small number of cases
typically involving account abuse okay
so if someone's abusing the the terms of
the Kindle of course they could
obliterate it it's not however in
Amazon's
interest to randomly go in and delete
your Kindle collection right or start
messing with you and saying I don't want
Ryan to read you know Infinite Jest
right and remove this from his Kindle so
he reads Fifty Shades of Grey still this
licensing of e-books instead of stacking
books on a shelf has altered our
psychological sense of how we connect to
what we read it's no longer truly ours
hmm good yeah that's awesome that is
great yeah because what really what he's
saying is as author our psychological
sense of how we can connect to what we
read connect to what we need I would say
yeah it allows us to more easily detach
from physical ownership of artifacts
that aren't adding value to our life
because it's up there in the cloud you
think of an album that you bought over a
decade ago but haven't listened to since
oh yeah absolutely I mean dude I had
when I was digitizing DVDs and CDs like
I remember I had that you know one
hundred two hundred book of CDs and like
a lot of them were like burnt CDs that
you know that someone had given me and I
just had like the songs listed out but I
remember just like going through the
probably 350 of them away
because you know well the the vast
reason why was because I was not
listening to those you know just 3/4 of
those CDs right I didn't see myself
listening to them in the near future
and if they're in the cloud it's easy to
let go of them because you know you'll
still have access to them in the future
if you do want to break out that Abba
album and you want to listen to it then
then you can but if you don't then you
don't and that's okay you've detached
from it yeah this technology is enable
us to detach more easily and I think
that's such a great thing dude you hit
the nail on the head with the experience
is what we get joy out of right and we
used to have to own these things in
order to access that experience yes and
dude it I mean it wasn't that long ago
20 years ago so so over the last 20
years I mean we have been evolving to
less ownership and more access and you
know I think this is just a this article
is a reaction to change it's a reaction
to this evolution that is that is
happening man but but again those those
experiences that we want with a CD with
a book yeah dude like we don't have to
own a physical copy we can access it
anytime yeah and I'm not against
ownership I are some physical books I
own a car but I also have access to more
books on my Kindle and I also have
access to lyft or uber if I if I want to
or those little bird scooters or
whatever like there are other means of
transportation or the subway system here
you know I have the ability to have
access to things without without having
to own every him you don't have a home
gym in your home you have access to the
equipment that other people share you
don't have to own every single weight
that's in your gym because I know you
lift all the way all right yeah and and
weights out of the back to add more
weight anyway back to this article here
the change in our relationship with
physical objects does not stop there we
used to buy DVDs or video cassettes now
viewers stream movies or TV shows with
Netflix good that is great
I feel like an 85 year old like angry
big money
yeah wrote this yeah yeah and I feel
like his father may have written like an
article about you know how he was mad
that eight tracks were turning into
cassette tapes or something right
even the company's disc mailing service
is falling out of favor good what would
I do with a DVD if you mailed one to me
a you your mailing something to me so
you're wasting all this packaging and
yeah and by the way it's gonna take more
people to ship the thing and yeah the
environmental costs alone yeah not worth
it absolutely and so yes it's falling
out of favor good if you sent me a DVD I
would have to go buy a DVD player to
play it right I don't want to have to do
that yeah music lovers used to buy
compact discs now Spotify and YouTube or
more commonly used to hear our favorite
tunes yeah uh-huh I have access to all I
don't have to carry around this damn CD
booklet or I used to have a 50 disc CD
changer in my trunk
yeah and it's crazy you know I've OCD so
I knew where what was in all 50 this oh
yeah it was alphabetizing the great
American Teenage Dream used to be to own
your own car that is dwindling in favor
of urban living greater reliance on mass
transit cycling walking and of course
ride-sharing services such as uber and
lyft you know this part this whole
article it just made me think of like
how so you look at Millennials and they
get such a bad rap dude yeah they get
such a bet oh they're lazy they don't
want to buy stuff anymore they don't
want to have to own a CD they want I
mean this sounds like it is I know
they're not specifically targeting
Millennials but it could be but they are
by proxy by proxy they are and here's
the thing man is that people nowadays
especially Millennials they want meaning
in their life they want to do something
that is purposeful they are not
after oh I'm going to get a job I'm
going to have a wife and two point three
kids and I'm going to have a my own
piece of land and maybe if I get rich
enough I can have my own theater I can
have all these things to pacify me I
mean that is that is what what we have
done as a culture over you know past
post-industrial age it's how much stuff
can we get how many pacifiers can we
bring into our lives right and
ultimately man that's what I hear this
article saying is it is people are
cutting back on their pacifiers per say
and yeah it's a good thing man or or
also people are sharing more frequent
right how's that again I go back to the
gym analogy right there was a time if
you wanted exercise equipment there was
not generally a local place to go to
work out or if there was it was far away
and now there's access to gyms and
pretty much every small town even I mean
we lived in Missoula Montana there's
probably 10 15 20 different gyms there
dude yeah I mean it had the nicest gym I
mean with Maher and I we belonged to
like then one of the nicest gyms in LA
when I say it's nice it is it's clean
you know awesome staff some pretty cool
amenities the leg that is doesn't even
touch what we had invisible anyway yeah
that was a little bit of a tangent well
III think the the nice thing the nice
thing is imagine how much would cost you
to buy everything you use at the gym
yeah tens of thousands of dollars yeah I
mean we're and by the way then you'd
also need the space to fill it and you
you'd be the one taking care of it and
you'd be washing the towels and I mean
all of these additional costs and so I
say good to all of us each of these
changes is beneficial yet I worried that
Americans are slowly but surely losing
their connection to the idea of private
ownership here's what I disagree with
this
so SoulCycle class you and I have gotten
the SoulCycle we talked about it last
week on the podcast I after going to
SoulCycle several times realize I'd like
to do this more
but I would like to do it when it's
appropriately timed for me and so backs
and I after a month or two months
actually of doing research and planning
and making sure that we could afford it
we bought a soul cycle bike basically
one there's actually better than you
would use in a soul cycle class because
it has like monitors and stuff but what
I got like the workouts on the monitors
yes yeah yeah and and also but it tells
you what your resistance is what your
cadence is oh it sounded like just a
little knob really yeah this feels right
you use the knob right and they'll tell
you like you cut your resistance is 35
now we're gonna move that resistance up
to 55 in action and so it's actually
more helpful than the SoulCycle class
for me but it's more helpful also
because I can use it like if I want to
use it at 7 o'clock in the morning or
whenever and I don't have to leave the
house to do it and I'm doing it much
more frequently as a result right now
the problem with that is a lot of people
well you and I talked about the Seth
Godin thing where his grandma bought the
exercise equipment she thought it would
do the work for her yeah yeah that's
often the problem we have with a lot of
ownership and so having access to that
SoulCycle class was the reason that I
brought this new bike into my life I
wouldn't have brought it into my life
otherwise because I would like I'm not
really sure I'm not sure if I'm going to
use it but once I started going this
whole song I like oh this is beneficial
to me but I want a way to be able to do
this in my house daily or every other
day right then I decided to own the
thing because it made sense for me the
same thing with with car ownership I
owned a car because it makes sense for
me it doesn't make sense for everyone
and if it doesn't make sense for you I
applaud you I say that's great if I
lived in Manhattan it would it would be
a burden for me to own a car I'd rather
have access and share that access with
everyone yeah yeah just like you said
man it sounds like we're going more
towards a sharing community
yeah the there's nothing wrong with
private ownership that's we certainly
aren't against that as you just
expressed with your with your exercise
bike but it you know it can it can get
dangerous with things like well you know
nowadays like people want their own home
theater mm-hmm like you used to go to
the theater
and it was an experience and you got out
you would see you know people in the
community I mean it's not a very
interactive experience with the
community but it was this way it was
this thing that would you know bring the
community together a little bit more now
you know people want to have their own
private home theater and that is the
that type of private ownership it can
just pull us away from being engaged
engaging with the community so I again
dude I totally love that we're heading
towards a sharing community yeah yeah
sure market the nation was based on the
notion that private ownership gives
individuals a stake in the system I
don't agree with that but we'll talk
with my mama read that sentence again
the nation was based on the notion that
private ownership gives individuals a
stake in the system Wow
I don't think that's what gave
individualist stake in the system I
think we we come from a relative Puritan
upbringing our country does and the
stake in the system was always hard work
right right and yeah I think and and now
well I'd like to see the shift go toward
instead of hard work as meaningful work
absolutely dude well you know what
though man the that stake in the system
with with ownership with private
ownership of something that is like a
false sense of having a stake it's like
it's like I don't know I I could liken
it to on the day where maybe I don't get
a whole lot done but I've caught up on
email and you know I've caught up on
social media and I feel like I got
something done today but really I didn't
really get anything done
there's nothing meaningful when we are
just catching up on things that's what
yeah that's another way say to men is it
might be maybe it is a stake and in our
society but it's not a very meaningful
stake in our society yeah yeah exactly
someone tweeted me recently are treated
at the minimalists and said well I I
disagree with the basically they said
something about I find this coffee mug
that I have to be so meaningful awesome
and
and like they said in a way that was
almost like belligerent and like you
guys are totally wrong I find my coffee
mug to be meaningful and you know my
response was well then you know when you
die you should ask your family to bury
you with it I mean because here's the
truth that we can't we can't bring we
don't own anything ultimately right like
we're just renting for the 80 years that
we are here yeah and then maybe we can
pass those rentals on to a future
generation or whatever and that's what
we want to talk about today is is what
does it mean to to curate so we're gonna
get back to this art over here it set
americans apart from feudal peasants
taught us how property rights and
incentives operate totally disagree
about that incentives operate not via
physical goods but we're incentivize to
do all kinds of things they have nothing
to do with private property or physical
ownership of physical goods yeah in fact
we don't pay people like it like podcast
Shawn or Jordan no more over here we
don't you know love you more yeah okay
yeah Jordan no more I and we don't pay
them in physical goods right hey did you
imagine here's a Casio watch this is a
week's worth of work and Shawn here is a
jar of jellybeans right the gentleman
like podcast on would love that George
jellybeans yeah he would his his
daughter's like just take it from him
anyway so yeah we we don't we
incentivize them not I don't give them
physical money even right you 90 over
90% of the the money that that's in our
country is digitized as well it's zeroes
and one right they're incentivized by
zeros and ones and it's what those other
zeros and ones get them and quite often
it's not the physical good it could be
Spotify or whatever right yeah you're
paying for Spotify with the zeros and
ones that we gave you and it was a kind
of training for future entrepreneurship
no today's entrepreneurs are often
selling services not physical goods mmm
do we not as parents give our children
pets or other valuable possessions to
teach them the basic lessons of life and
stewardship no I've never given a pet
teacher stewardship we're hardly at a
point where Americans properly property
has been abolished but I am still
nervous that we are finding ownership to
be so inconvenient again yes we're
talking about convenience the
convenience economy the access economy
the reason that we live in a city is you
walked here today you didn't have to
take a car dude ownership is
inconvenient quite often it is dude and
sometimes it is convenient we just yeah
yeah sometimes but like we just moved
Mariah and I just moved to a new
apartment and I mean it took the movers
for hours like from time of picking up
our stuff to going 30 minutes across
town stopping a podcast Sean's place to
drop off a mattress that we didn't need
anymore
mm-hmm then go in our place and loading
everything up to our place it took them
four hours hmm that's convenient man
yeah and and can you imagine if you were
calling right he could move in for
minutes right and because he's not
inconvenienced by all the stuff right
yawns fifty-two items or whatever it is
yeah and and that's it by the way check
out Colin right on tour becoming tor.com
owning a car is inconvenient man I mean
if I could do a rideshare everywhere I
went it wasn't ungodly expensive I'd do
that in LA having a car makes it a
little bit better a little less
expensive getting from point A to point
B but ultimately dude I hate owning a
car I got to change the oil in the thing
clean the thing I got a there's so many
other other aspects of owning a car
besides just parking it in my garage and
then working I need it yeah surance and
all the now I've got I don't know
so in remember a little rough spot that
was on the passenger yeah a passenger
side of the back door it uh it is like
there's nothing there not because of the
salt from the ocean
it's just like a matter of time before I
think I gotta do something I get either
got to replace the door I don't know I
gotta do something about it but anyway
but just that one thing dude like I was
thinking about that last time like it
fighting on the car I don't have to
worry about this stupid rough spot yeah
yeah you don't want a car you don't you
don't have rust problem rent on your car
yeah what about your iPhone that all
essential life device surely you own
that well sort of when Apple Inc decides
to change the operating software sooner
or later you have to go along with what
they have selected Gmail is due to
change its overall look and
functionality maybe for the better but
again eventually this choice will not be
yours either yeah I don't want to design
the software for my gmail account I
would prefer to let the experts the the
curators yeah allow them to do that
because here's here's how the market
works
Tyler the market works that if we hate
the thing then we move on to something
else Skype has had this problem recently
they forced people to upgrade to
whatever the new software system was and
then Microsoft got so many complaints
that they actually had to go back and
say okay we're gonna we're gonna allow
you to have this old version it's
different from the mobile version that's
how the market works because if you
don't like the thing you move on to the
the better thing now we we can talk
about how some some companies develop a
monopoly that's a different kind of
problem right oh if it's YouTube it's
not a true monopoly because you could
put something we could put this video on
Vimeo and so we could talk about maybe
some of these things should be
considered public utilities like Google
or YouTube I don't necessarily believe
so but I think there can be good
arguments for that that's completely
different from the argument he's making
here for physical ownership yes I would
prefer the Gmail figures out there
interface instead of allowing me to
design their interface for them right
unless you're like Derek Siver's who has
their own email they're almost like
there's no server yeah but yeah but but
again the lake that's his preference
yeah and here's the thing dude is that
is a that is a you have to have the
knowledge I want to set that up
you have to afford that and you know
Gmail this example that they're using
yes like maybe we don't have full
control over it it's your point it's
good we don't because we don't
understand how to make a email service
but it also makes it more accessible
like Gmail is free right and if you
don't like Gmail you can use another
Yahoo Hotmail or one of the other ones
yeah but there are a bunch of other ones
yeah there are absolutely you know I
always I see people like with the cell
friends like in Cincinnati or though
Senseo are are calm there's plenty out
there
imagine the Internet of Things
penetrating our homes and more through
services like Amazon's Alexa kill Ryan
Nicodemus will have ovens and
thermostats that you set with your voice
that's pretty cool in a toilet in a
bathroom that periodically give you the
equivalent of a medical check-up not
true but okay yes you will still own the
title to your physical house but most of
the value in that home you will in
essence rent from outside companies or
in the case of municipal utilities the
government yeah yeah I do get my water
from the government and and you know
what that's okay because I don't want to
have to go to a well every day yeah and
and get the water and then heat it up I
would argue that anything we think we
own anyways I mean it if anything on a
long enough time timeline is ephemeral
right right so I mean we really don't
own anything anyway man right it's all
gonna go away eventually I mean yeah we
could pass it down but I just argue that
the the the the concept of ownership it
well let's adjust that it's a concept
and because people accept the concept
then then yes ownership is a thing but
ultimately I mean it's yeah you're right
it's all borrowed yeah so I'm gonna put
a shot if you could put a link to this
in the show notes here I'll hand this
over to you now so you have it if you
could put a link to that podcast Sean on
the show notes
the restaurant worker goes on but that's
our bit of a rant on on ownership versus
access you know what I am for both I
want to own certain things I want to
have access to certain things and I want
that to change over time sometimes I
might want to own a car but there may be
a point in time where I just want access
to a car maybe I want to stop owning the
thing all together or I might want to
own a house or I might want to rent a
house that's access to out when we
travel on tour we have access to a room
either Airbnb or a hotel I don't wanna
buy a house right I go to Nashville for
a week right all right so I tell you
what let's dive into some of these
voicemails if you're good with that Ryan
let's do a man our first question today
is from Tracy in Pennsylvania Lewisburg
I'm a full-time stay-at-home mother
prior to this I had a career as a
collections manager for art museum my
job was literally to make sure that as
many objects as possible existed for as
long as possible in their physical or
digital space I love museums and they
bring a lot of value to my life and I
hope they will bring value to my
children's lives and my grandchildren's
lives but the line between Grandma's
house which is stuffed to the rafters
with treasures for her grandchildren and
warehouses of museum collections is
starting to feel blurry to me I have no
idea if or when I will go back to work
outside the home or if I will return to
my previous career but I'm wondering
what your thoughts are on museums and
natural or cultural history collection
yeah the thing that she said Ryan was
one cannot know what wide value of
future generations
I think that's simply not true you can
know certain things aren't going to add
any value at all and the treasures at
Grandma's house quite often are a burden
on the future generation yeah one can
know what will burden the future
generations not not with everything but
if we can discern pretty quickly the the
junk from the essentials
yeah and and then that that middle
ground what is non-essential what are
the things that add value we can figure
out some of those things are actually
junk we're kidding ourselves when we
think all of these things now
she used to be Traci used to be a
Collections Manager at a museum so for
all intents and purposes she was a a
curator so I was walking around last
night just thinking about curation
versus collecting and I think museums
are actually the places that that do it
really well so so what makes a museum
beautiful is the same thing that that I
had a piece of sourdough bread recently
mm-hmm and the thing that makes that a
piece of sourdough bread delicious how'd
that make you feel sorry oh yeah with
what yours I've got a health update
later on okay all right today so we'll
do that during right here right now
segment but a piece of sourdough bread a
really good piece sourdough bread bread
it's very light and airy yeah the thing
that makes it delicious is that sort of
negative space the airy parts when you
go to a museum it's wide open and
beautiful or architects call it the
negative space mmm if you have a set of
columns the columns that are tall and
gorgeous because of the space in between
them the space in between the emptiness
are the parts that are just as important
as what is there physically I've
listened to a podcast with Rob Bell
recently he was talking about the
nothing is something with that negative
space that is actually part of of the
curation knowing what should be there
but then also what shouldn't be there
you and I have gone to a lot of museums
and we're out on tour right now and and
the ones that stand out the most are
tend to be sparse
because that which is meaningful is
highlighted by the vast emptiness around
it yeah it's one of the the reasons that
I find tiny homes less appealing to me
personally I applaud people who really
like tiny homes and get a lot of value
from them but for me part of the reason
I don't own a lot of things but I like
having the the negative space
in my you know 900 square foot home as
opposed to having all of that those
things in two hundred three hundred
square feet and crammed together yeah I
like the beauty the the aesthetics and
when I think about the museum's that
have stood out most to me whether it's
in in Des Moines or you go to the LACMA
or wherever are they getting yeah yeah
yeah it's yeah it's it's the the museum
buildings themselves are what make those
museums awesome for me they have great
collections as well yes but you're
absolutely right like every single bit
of detail in the Getty and the one in
Des Moines specifically every single
architectural detail is considering the
negative space it's considering how the
curation of art is being presented how
the collection of art is way present
yeah with the with the building and so I
love what you just said about about they
have great collections but if it was
just the collection imagine going to a
storage unit on the edge of town and
Franklin Ohio yeah and and all of a
sudden in there you have the Mona Lisa
the Mona Lisa you have a Picasso
painting they just stacked you amongst
boxes of other junk right yeah figurines
and statues and you have junk in there
with this collection of beautiful art
would that art evoke the same feelings
and emotions no you'd be like that's
beautiful but why isn't it
why aren't we treating it appropriately
that's what curators do and so I wrote
down this thing last night
good curators createspace collectors
just fill space hmm you could put that
as a minimal maximum podcast Sean it's
good man yeah I know it it's I totally
agree III was I was listening to a
podcast this this past week Jon
Caramanica he's the music critic for the
New York Times and he has a weekly
podcast called the pop cast and and this
week they were talking about merchandise
and how some merchandise has actually
been arced over the years like bands
have have incorporated not just like
well we're gonna sell as many t-shirts
as possible but we're going to
a way to make this part of the
experience how can we create sort of
folk art and physical goods and he
actually has the best use I certainly
wouldn't call Jon Caramanica a
minimalist but is the best use I've ever
heard of as a storage locker he he has a
storage locker for he collects
merchandise now he doesn't do a good job
curating the merchandise factor that's
one of the jokes he was making with the
guy there's a store and I think in Soho
where they take these old vintage pieces
of merchandise and they treat it like
art and they sell these you know
t-shirts and old vinyls and and and
these goods from decades past
music there's a store that curates those
really well now Jon Caramanica has a
collection just sitting in a storage
locker and my argument would be and this
is applicable to Tracy is you're going
to get far more value from the
collection if you're able to curate it
appropriately and that's why museums
stand out to us so much because they
don't just take all the art they have
access to and cram it into a room mm-hmm
that that doesn't feel like art that
doesn't feel like intentional use of the
space when you go somewhere like like
LACMA it feels like they're using that
space intentionally yeah it creates a
set of emotions they use the space to
make you feel something about the art
the space itself including the negative
space and he is part of the art
absolutely yeah I really appreciate
professional curators like Tracy I think
that the world needs professional
curators I am NOT a professional curator
so I leave the curating up to the
professionals I think that's an
important point an important important
point because Ryan we agree that a
museum curator I mean what that's one
out of every 1 million people as a
museum curator there aren't that many of
them let the professional curators
handle the curation of large collections
in the Library of Congress and all right
I was doing it I would just hold on to
everything
right and there would be no curation it
would be just a hoard and then all we
need to do is curate our own spaces
absolutely then you know I mean just to
to Tracy's point like she is a
professional curator was was uh yeah
she's been on it for about a year but
what I'll say is that there is a
difference though between yes there is a
difference between one person or an
organization curating a collection of
things they have a collection that they
are curating and then you've got a
person who is a hoarder and there is a
there is a very big difference between
the two right um you know as far as what
what adds value to the future
generations I was thinking about this
lake I'm trying to think of an example
of something maybe a hundred years ago
that we wish we would have held on to
that we didn't hold on to I not anything
I'm sure there's an exception you know
I'm sure there's I'm sure there isn't
yeah I'm sure there's an answer but like
all in all man you're right like there
there isn't there isn't a way to to sit
here in and guess what is gonna add add
value to the future generations but but
if we if we go at it with that attitude
then I mean it's just a slippery slope
manly absolutely everything we could
find an excuse for everything that
optimize for an excuse yeah
what was the the art museum was that in
Tasmania where there was like literally
poop oh dude yeah I mean this yeah it
was so genius this dude made a there are
different stages to digestion uh-huh so
what he did is he took baby poop mm-hmm
and took flora from baby poop he
basically made this machine that had the
different stages of digestion so he put
food into the first what would which
would you know represent like the
stomach with the acid and then he put
the flora in there and then it goes to
these different stages of the digestion
track and then it eventually makes poop
mm-hmm and yeah dude it that I I love
how that artist just basically I think
what he did is in his head he's was like
I'm going to literally make [ __ ]
yes and I'm going to make it art well
that there's a David Foster Wallace
story called the suffering Channel and
it it takes part of the story involves
an artist who basically turns his own
feces into art and and it's a beautiful
metaphor for and especially because it
takes place in August of 2001 like right
and and the the magazine that's covering
him happens to be in the Twin Towers and
and it was this perfect metaphor of life
we're spending our wasting our time
talking about [ __ ] literally yeah and
when you know what's about to happen to
these people who were in the Twin Towers
like you're all these people are going
to die life is ephemeral and we're so
worried about [ __ ] yeah and and that is
exactly what is going on with most of
the stuff that we're we're dealing with
her we're holding her for future
generations
we had Ryan Delk on the podcast and he
was talking about how you can optimize
for almost anything you know you can say
well I better hold on to everything so I
have this optimal amount of stuff you
can scrutinize and it's important to
scrutinize and you know what you might
not be all you might not might not be
right all the time but back to the theme
so I'm from Peter Doran mmm-hmm I bet
you'll be just fine without him yeah and
I think that's the the thing to keep in
mind a few other things that I wrote
down well I was gonna say the one before
you before you go onto the next thought
the one thing that I will say that
frustrates me so bad is the libraries
that have been destroyed throughout
history so like Alexander the Great
destroyed Cleopatra's library with all
the information on how pyramids were
built and just collections of books so
there are there are certain bits of
information that we do need to hold on
to now we can store those digitally we
don't have to have physical books right
but there certainly are there is
definitely information that we need to
pass on thee like the Aztecs they built
like [ __ ] chanita they don't understand
how they were able to precisely measure
when it comes to acoustics to make the
acoustics the way that they were I mean
there's a certain point where there's a
I figure what the game is called but
there's a field that they play this game
on and it's about 200
and literally I could stand at one end
you stand at the other and then I could
just talk like this yeah and like you
would be able to hear me whispering
right and all that information is lost
because of basically you know Christians
coming through and this stuff's pagan
we're getting rid of it right so so you
know just just to the point of like
there are things that we do want to pass
down from generation to generation to me
I think knowledge like that is something
that might be missed that I can't think
of anything else but knowledge is
definitely something that we want to
keep intact and that knowledge is not
necessarily a result of the physical
artifacts back then that was they'll
know where we had to capture the
information right now we have ways of
capturing information whether it is
physical or digital that we can pass on
and we can make we can make redundancies
I mean even we do this podcast you know
Shawn has certain redundancy set up or
with our website we have redundancies
set up so if it gets if it gets deleted
we make sure there's some sort of
redundancy I with my photos that I
scanned with the scanning party it's in
the cloud but I also have a hard drive I
don't have a physical copy of them
anymore but I have several redundancy so
I can pass that information those zeros
and ones right on in the future if I
want to I think it's important to
digitize whenever we can we can take
photos of things that we want to
preserve the those triggers for memories
yeah if we want to preserve those photos
is taking a photo is a great way to do
it but you don't need to hold on to the
large artifact in order to do that but
here's the thing when you curate all of
those things when it's grandma's home
full of all this excess if you kept just
the things that that were that we found
to be most meaningful and we'll talk
about how things themselves don't have
intrinsic meaning but but if we if we we
get more value from having fewer things
and if we water them down with a
hoarders existence
yeah and so we need to trust the
curators who are professional curators
to curate the museums or the libraries
but then we need to trust ourselves to
curate our own spaces in our own homes
and our own things and I wrote this down
here I I wrote down that that the
curators are important otherwise anyone
could put art in a museum
imagine if you could just go to lack of
money so I know I drew this painting I'm
just gonna put it up on the wall here
thanks he totally did that don't forget
what museum but there are people who
have done it but you know when you go to
like a Panera Bread or something I've
got that community quirk board this is
junk everywhere all over the court oh
yeah it almost like indiscernible like
you look at it you don't you you want to
turn away from it because it's so
distracting and so overwhelming that's
because it has not been professionally
curated anyone can put some sort of
notice up there yo check out my band or
check out this movie or whatever it is
and there are other places like the
whole food local Whole Foods where you
have to like hand them the poster they
have to approve it and then they put it
up and as I'm waiting in line at the
bathroom of Whole Foods I always check
that out because there's like a few
things there and like oh I didn't
realize that movie was coming out or or
whatever and it's because those are
things that they've approved they've
curated it but if it was if it was just
the the cork board where anyone could
post something to it then all of a
sudden it's like oh this isn't curated
I'm just gonna turn away from them
because it's overwhelming right and
that's where we've gotten with our stuff
we are overwhelmed with our stuff and
the way to become less overwhelm less
anxious is to well it's the cure rate
right so so this thing that Seth Godin
talked about in his podcast recently
said without curation there is a race to
the bottom now I think about YouTube
which we're on right now or Amazon
Kindle books which were on as well
they've enabled us to reach a large
audience of people we're in the top 1%
of all Kindle books so we're in the top
1% of all YouTube channels even though
we don't even have that many YouTube
followers but because anyone can start a
YouTube channel there are plenty of
people with one subscriber or two
subscribers or 100 subscribers or
whatever and and so the barrier of entry
is functionally zero right it's next to
zero I should say there's a small
barrier of entry you have to figure how
to use a computer and stuff but
pretty much anyone can start their own
YouTube book right you don't need
permission from like ABC or NBC those
used to be like in order to have a TV
show and have a show you needed one of
those three networks right then there's
a fourth network that came along and oh
my goodness now we have 33% more content
yeah and now it's a it's unlimited
content right it's and and it would be
impossible to consume all the content
that's out there and yeah in a lifetime
yes single lifetime absolutely and in
fact I think there's what a lifetime of
videos posted every hour on I mean it's
unbelievable yeah so there's so much out
there and so there is a race to the
bottom meaning there's a lot of junk out
there there's a lot of uh you know
what's some junk that's on YouTube
fouseytube I mean every cat video but
here so cat videos or or fouseytube I
mean phousi has over 10 million
followers on YouTube so it obviously
adds value to some people right but it's
it's not so we have different types of
curation on YouTube it's not the
traditional curation so Amazon when our
audience goes and buys our books it
starts to recommend them if you like
this book you also like this book and
and people are able to rake them a
certain way same with YouTube more
comments or or more shares there's an
algorithm that YouTube will use so if
you comment on this video or if you
share it with other people then YouTube
if your thumbs up it then then YouTube
will say or if you subscribe to the
channel even right the YouTube will say
well we'll put that into the algorithm
some more people will have exposure to
this right and so there is even a type
of curation there even though there's
functionally unlimited videos you're not
gonna have access to most of them yeah
you're not gonna find them unless you're
searching for it specifically right
right and so there is a different type
of curation that's happening there there
is an unlimited amount of stuff there
just like you go to a grocery store you
have on a functionally unlimited amount
of food there but you can find the
things that you're going to want to eat
and you can leave the store with just
those you don't have to eat everything
in the store and so I guess the thing I
would say to Tracy to sum this all up is
you understand what you want and let go
of the rest and what I mean by one is
like what's what's going to add value to
your life what's gonna add value to your
kid's life and then what's gonna burden
them as well I can give you the advice
what's gonna add vitae my life or what's
gonna add value to Ryan's life but it's
not about what would Ryan do it's about
what would Tracy do what would Sarah do
what would Jim do what would Jeff do
whoever's listening to this what would
you do what's appropriate for you
because what's appropriate for you may
not be appropriate for me and vice versa
so what do you want and once you figure
that out it becomes so much easier once
you get clear on the things that are
gonna add value to your life it becomes
clear that the rest of those things are
just a burden and when something's a
burden it's so much easier to let go of
it because it's in the way of a more
meaningful life absolutely Tracy I'd
love to send you a copy of our book
everything that remains it's it's really
the story of two guys trying to find a
well curated life it's the story of me
and Ryan curating our lives over this
this five-year period in our late 20s we
discovered this thing called minimalism
we walked away from the corporate world
and we began curating our own lives
through Ryan's packing party or through
me letting go of 90% of my possessions
over the course of eight months but then
also curating our relationships letting
go of toxic relationships bringing new
people into our lives creating more and
consuming less it's the story of that
five year period of our lives I think
you'll find a lot of value in that a lot
of helpful tips in there as well Shawn
if you reach out to Tracy give her the
audiobook version of this book or if she
wants the book book or the ebook version
we're happy to give Tracy one of those
as well our next question is from Brynn
also in Pennsylvania how do you deal
with special items you bought or
otherwise gotten on vacation for example
I have a conch-shell that I found on
vacation and it doesn't really add value
to my life but I'm having trouble
getting rid of it because it
one of those caught on coats special or
cool things you find on the vacation
another example is if you go to Ireland
and buy a wool sweater and you don't
really find yourself wearing it that
much but you want to keep it for the
novelty of saying you've got a wool
sweater in Ireland how do you deal with
these items if the memory of a fun trip
is associated with them so Ryan I was
thinking about the to go back to the
museums for a second because I think
this is really applicable to Bryn's
question here she's all about dealing
with souvenirs I also think the real
problem with museums is like the
curation they have that down for me the
real problem is the consumerism the the
exit through the gift shop yeah I mean
there's a whole reason that Banksy made
the movie exit through the gift shop was
to expose the consumerism of the art
world not just the the money that's tied
to art that's a maybe a separate problem
how there's this over inflation of the
price of art these days but also the
sort of the trinket the trinket ization
of of the art world where literally a
lot of museums we go to you were forced
to exit through the gift shops because
they know that everyone at that museum
what's the prove that they were at the
Museum people want to have a little
trinket a little token facet that that
Ramez them maybe triggers a memory of
the museum or they can go to their
friend be like oh look I got this at the
Lachman this is proof that I was at the
LACMA right and like that is why we exit
through the gift shop that's why they
have us exit through the gift shop like
they are playing to this to this need
that we have to it whether it's to
impress someone else or whether it's to
prove to ourself something there is
something affirming I'm not saying that
it's like a good way to affirm but what
museums know is that all that stuff in
the gift shop there is some type of
affirmation that a trinket will give
someone temporarily or or you know maybe
they're sure there's a trinket out there
that someone has a real
really love I always talking about my
sign my grandma got me I really enjoy it
I like having it if it spontaneously
combusted I wouldn't be you'd be just
fine yeah I wouldn't be I wouldn't be
upset about it but I but I really do
enjoy having it but yes playing to that
having to prove ourselves that is
exactly why we exit through the gift
shop like when I think about Brent's
question we always talk about the why
that's what we always look at man why
are we doing these things right and you
know with Bryn's situation I would look
at why Bren why are you feeling like you
have to hold on to that conch shell what
they said was is oh this is like a cool
trinket that I should have yeah is it is
it is it you should have it because you
Brynn really get a lot of value out of
the conch shell or is it because other
people say oh you should have a conch
shell um I mean when I like I'm putting
myself in Brent's shoes I'm thinking
about maybe if like we had it so people
over for dinner on Sunday night and if I
had a conch shell sitting on my table be
great conversation starter well
especially as a minimalist cuz people
would be like what's up with a gong show
just sitting there but you know that I
could be like oh I went on this great
vacation and and let me let me tell you
about this amazing time that I had now
when when we tell stories like that or
when we're sharing an experience you
know I would I would I would challenge
Brenda asked themselves like are you
sharing that experience to impress are
you sharing that experience to be better
are you sharing that experience to make
someone jealous or are you legitimately
sharing this joy that you had with a
vacation the verbage that Brynn used
with the shell and use with the sweater
it sounds like it they're not hanging on
to the shell right - for them they're
hanging on for it to be cool they
literally said this is a cool drink that
I'm supposed to hold on to suppose -
right I think I was - according to whom
right and I've got this I've got this
sweater from Ireland and and look at
this wool sweater you know how Harlan
isn't known for their wool and well here
it is I got the wool from Ireland I know
and I'm
and Bryn has got to ask themselves like
are you doing that for you or are you
are you doing that for other people
again even with the sweater it sounds
like Bren might be holding on to this
sweater for other people yeah so they so
what would it Brin say um you know I
have this wool sweater that you're
supposed to have from Ireland that that
that you know proves that you were there
and and to your point and like who who
says that you're supposed to have it if
it's Brynn then great right like awesome
even then not great it's a slippery
slope else of the suppose think so I
don't have a problem with either one of
these items in fact if that's all you're
really struggling with is one
consciousness shell and a sweater cutter
and that's what you feel like you're
supposed to have like a problem they
don't take a conch shell and the sweater
won't take up much space they're not a
problem they're symptoms of a greater
problem as you said that I'm supposed to
have these things because I want to
impress other people here that here's
the the honest truth you're not
impressing anyone with a wool sweater
and if you are you you're probably
impressing the wrong types of people the
person who is impressed by the conscious
shell Wow well I would I would just
question who I was associating with at
that point this this to me is a symptom
of another well maybe not a symptom but
it's it's it's like a parallel to social
media how so because this conch shell in
this sweater is something that Bren can
have to be to say hey look at me I've
done a lot of traveling and I got this
stuff to prove it and social media is
this hey look at me I'm having a blast
that my life is awesome and I've got all
the pictures to prove it
and we've got to be careful with getting
back to the why we have to be very
careful with why we're doing these
things so Brynn why are you holding on
to this sweater because you think it's
cool there's a there is a deeper meaning
there is it big is it cool to you or is
it because it's cool to other people the
same thing with a conch shell it's a
nice little trinket from vacation is it
because it's a nice little trinket for
you or is it something that you feel
like you need to show to other people
when when I think when we get to that
why when we when with these things
especially with souvenirs and it
translates over to social media when we
are talking about our experiences when
we're sharing our meaningful lives with
other people are we doing it in a
genuine way why are we sharing it are we
doing it with the intent to make someone
jealous or are we doing it because we're
we're including people not excluding
people
so she as a minimalist everything I own
serves a purpose or it brings me joy now
a sweater could certainly serve a
purpose
yeah keep you warm it can also bring you
joy you look great in a cardigan man
thank you
the the conch shell could also bring its
product I serve a purpose but it could
bring you joy it's a beautiful art piece
that you that you just enjoy maybe you
never talk about it but you just like
the way it looks I have this like glass
joke art piece at at our home and like I
don't talk to people about it but like I
just like the way it looks I think it's
beautiful
and so it brings me joy I don't you know
I don't put like a straw in it and drink
from it or anything but it so doesn't it
doesn't serve a purpose in that respect
other than I think aesthetically it is
beautiful and you know what dude
you think it's beautiful yeah Rebecca
thinks it's beautiful uh-huh and you
could give two shits without her thinks
about it oh yeah he's five I'm just I
tell her what's beautiful I'd know of
what I was really gonna say and you can
give two shits what other people think
about it yeah I mean what matters is is
what you and Rebecca have curated for
your home in that getting back to the
why why do you have that glass jug
because you and Becks really enjoy it
it's a great art piece and you really
love what I didn't say well yeah you
love having a lot of experience yeah you
love the experience of having a
beautiful home in general right I don't
love the things themselves right I love
the experience that the the home gives
to me but also the other people who are
rarely very rarely there in my home and
that's a good way of looking at it too
the jug adds to your experience so maybe
that's how Brent or anyone else you know
kind of struggling with this this feel
of what I should or shouldn't have
what's cool to have what's not cool that
you know what is that thing
serving is it serving the experience or
is it serving something else I mean when
I think about I had this thought last
night about how oh I'm trying not to get
back into my mommy and daddy issues
because I don't want to go too much on a
tangent but a long story short I was
just going back to to to having that
that perspective of you know my father
is who he is and he uses this this
organization as a tool to be you know
who he to be a version of who he already
is to be a bad parent so so to to look
at that on a broader scale last night I
was like wait a minute everything we do
everything we have these are all tools
everything I own is an extension of me
every experience I have is an extension
of me and I guess when it comes to
owning you know souvenirs we have to ask
like how is that tool serving a
meaningful life if that whether it's
whether it's you know a set of ideology
whether it's a set of beliefs or whether
it is a collection of souvenirs we have
to ask ourselves what are those tools
serving are they serving a meaningful
life or aren't they
or are they getting in the way right
exactly yeah so so I think curation when
it comes down to curating whether it's
the souvenirs or just the other things
in our life curation is really about is
curation is deliberate collecting and
there is nothing deliberate about
collecting everything right every time
we go to a new place to bring some new
trinket in so I think the first thing to
think about is stop bringing in
souvenirs going forward step number one
yeah dude I have been on it's funny I
have a section in my Gmail with travel
and then I've got like folders
underneath it for every trip that Mariah
and I have taken for you know putting
filing airline tickets filing receipts
filing reservation whatever it may be
I've got a folder that I can put all
these emails in and go to and I'm
looking at Tokyo Germany Europe I'm
looking at all these awesome places we
have been yeah I don't have one freaking
souvenir for any of them right and like
I
feel bad about that at all we have
plenty of memories and yes and that's a
word that Brynn use the memory
associated with them of course the
memories aren't in the things the the
memories are in us and you do have some
photos from those places that can help
you trigger the memories but even then
you don't feel compelled to take your
phone out and snap a photo every single
place you go either right
yeah often a good memory stick
absolutely man you know it's funny I
when I was looking at the that folder I
felt Tokyo and I remember
Mariah talked me out this is this is why
I love having her in my life like she
talked me out of buying this it was like
a pagoda statue that it was only like
this big and it was like you know ten
but quit Alona ten bucks or something
and I was like man that is like a nice
cool little art piece and you know maybe
maybe I'll like it and she was like I
don't know like we're gonna put that in
the house and and I'm like oh yeah
you're right like I don't really know
where we would have put that and I you
know I passed on it and I could have
went back and got it you know while I
was there in Tokyo but looking back on
that situation like I don't regret not
getting that pagoda statue like I am
very content not having a trinket that I
can look at be like oh yeah that's from
Tokyo well that's helpful to having
someone else in the house and Becks and
I have a rule that if we both don't get
value from something that's in the house
then we agree to not bring it into the
house yeah
now agreeing on that beforehand it's
harder once you have a house full of all
the stuff and you're like but no that's
mine
really what I what I've agreed to is I'm
willing to let go of anything I'm
willing to walk away from anything and
I'm also willing to avoid bringing the
thing into the house
if Beck's isn't going to get some sort
of value from it as well now sometimes
with Beck's could be she's gonna get so
much value from the thing that that that
by-proxy brings me value even if I'm not
going to use it you know she has this
kettlebell that she uses almost every
day
I don't I don't use the kettlebell but
she uses it and like so if she gets
immense value from it so I'm like well
of course I get value by proxy then
right but if there's something else that
I wanted to bring into the house we're
just gonna take up space in this corner
or whatever then she has to agree that
that is the best use of that space we
not just she
degree we both have to agree that is the
best use of that space and sometimes
well say no I don't think it is and we
have to be okay with that and it allows
us to bring far fewer things in to the
house now she she mentioned house these
are special items the conch shell and
the sweater are special special items
well it's only special Bryn it's only
special if you say it's special mm-hmm
it's a sweater I mean when you say
something out loud like this yeah but
it's a special sweater this sweater is
so special it's like when I walk by I
was walking down maybe yeah go ahead I
was walking out Fairfax Avenue yesterday
and like there there's like some
sandwich board sign outside for this $18
rug and is like special special $18 rug
no it's not actually special just
because you say it's special right and
but at the same time it's only special
because you say it's special God the
word sounds the word special sounds
weird to me no it really does so so hear
it maybe maybe use the word precious
yeah if something is too precious to me
I try to find a way to let it go oh yeah
and because I start question like why is
this so precious when it comes to
physical objects yes yeah physical goods
themselves if it's so precious that
means I'm giving it too much meaning I'm
making it too special you know this is
why I'm like I've decided recently did
not get a Tesla I don't know if I've
announced that you talked about on the
podcast yeah don't talk about it yet so
it's like NASA announcement I will not
be getting a Tesla breaking news every
week just a little flash breaking yes
you got me Jordans on it did you see the
one he did last week with the lightning
and the dog petting no I see oh it's so
good that's all I'm heading a dog in
last week's YouTube audio of the check
it out
but the reason another reason that I
know I didn't mention on last week's
podcast
about the Tesla is if I got a Tesla and
I denied you know saved for the next you
know two or three years and was able to
save up enough money to buy a Tesla well
then now I got a brand new car mm-hmm
that's gonna be too precious for me I'm
gonna hate when it gets scratched I'm
gonna be annoyed when it's dirty I am
it's good to be so precious to me that
it's going to affect my mood it's gonna
affect my day it's gonna affect my time
and attention that are the two most
important resources we have and that is
what a you to to your point I think
that's what happens when things become
too precious so that that ultimately is
I mean that's kind of like the already
decided not to really invest in it for
the reasons that I said in last week's
podcast also because a car is not an
investment it's a depreciating yes
absolutely yeah absolutely but the icing
on the cake for me I guess or like the
the final nail in the coffin for the
tech for the Tesla is that what a nail
on the icing ya nail on the icing that's
alright man is the is it is that that
holding it so precious yeah and it
constantly being on my mind like not
wanting to have that responsibility so I
don't know in a house right now like you
know you and I've been talking about
doing some like property investment type
stuff and you know the thought of being
a landlord yeah it might be a good
investment but dude that's gonna take up
time and attention yeah owning a new car
is gonna take up time and attention when
something is precious it will eat up
some of our time and attention and I
want to keep that as much of those
resources as possible or use those as
deliberately as possible yeah last week
we talked about the five most precious
resources that acronym we have steam st
e am skills and then time energy
attention and money and in buying a
house so I owned a house in Dayton Ohio
rental property and it requires all of
those less so of the skill but also but
my skills require the were required to
make the money in order to buy a house
right and thankfully backs is the one
who agreed to give up her resources
she's the one who manages the property
we also have a local property manager
there
but it takes her time it takes her
energy it takes her attention
those three precious resources not the
physical goods themselves the house
itself isn't precious to me
it's just a house it's a it's a rental
property income and if the house were to
burn down tomorrow I have insurance and
I'd be okay I'd be just fine without it
yeah
the two things for last things for bran
right before this we were doing the
YouTube pre-roll video that we do every
week we just do a quick pre-roll thing
and one of the questions that came out
the person said you know the thing I
struggle with with my collections is
always trying to complete the collection
I think we often treat collections as if
once we have the perfect collection it's
a the scene from Fight Club where he's
like I almost have my apartment just
right like it's gonna complete us in
some way dude I would there's some kind
of like psychological thing there man
like for someone who has a collection
and they feel incomplete as a person
because they don't have the entire
collection leg there if they ever
completed that collection like god help
them because they're gonna have to move
on to another collection or they're
gonna be faced with why they're actually
feeling like they're not a complete
person you start to feel lost yeah I I
had that so you know with me and my OCD
I had all kinds of collections we've
talked about we did a collecting podcast
so I think it was episode 118 and we in
there I talked about some of the things
I struggle with throughout my 20s like
DVD collections or Al Pacino memorabilia
like really random stupid things when I
go back but I would have a collection
and soon as I felt like either completed
the collection or I more than complete
because there's something you can't
complete the collection right having a
bundle Aqaba Teno memorabilia here like
there's an endless supply that stuff I'm
sure and so if you give an overabundance
I guess it's complete but then yeah I
didn't had to move on to whatever the
next thing was just cuz you complete one
thing you you you know as an author I
know this you finish one book and then
all of a sudden it's like all right
start the next book yeah and so you have
to find a way to enjoy the process of
writing the book or those things you
to enjoy the things not the act of
completing owning the things because it
doesn't become more precious once you
complete the collection now you just
have all this excess stuff you've
completed the excess I would encourage
anyone out there who you know is is
facing this where they've got a
collection of things but they don't have
the the complete collection and they
feel incomplete without it I would I
would you know challenge them to ask
themselves why do they feel incomplete
without the collection and I would even
bring that a step further and see if
they can maybe you know change the maybe
it's the internal dialogue or whatever
feeling it is that they are feeding into
with this collection right so really to
really try and work towards feeling
complete without having the complete
collection because that's power man like
being able to feel complete without
having a complete collection like that
is gonna that's gonna I imagine I mean
not even imagine like I I firmly believe
that that right there sounds like a much
more meaningful life than oh I got to
make sure I have this this you know
entire complete collection and the other
thing too is if if there is someone out
there who's like oh man I don't know I
don't know you know I can't get this
last bit of this collection and I don't
know how I'm gonna get in I don't feel
complete ask yourself is there something
else going on deeper inside why you
don't feel complete because getting the
you know collecting them all like that
is going to be temporary relief from the
incompleteness that you're feeling
yeah the definition of complete needs to
change for you you are already complete
you're breathing yeah you're alive
you're complete even if you're in an
empty room the question then becomes
what are the things they're gonna
enhance my experience of life
yeah and guess what it's not the full
collection of micro machines from 1987
and and so one last thing for Brin here
you're gonna have to let go of some
stuff because you're over complete right
now
and so this is si it's coming out on our
website it'll actually be out by the
time this podcast comes out it already
be on our website it's not just about
letting go this this one's called let go
the best you can yeah it's really sure
we look around our homes and see
everything we once wanted everything
that was supposed to make our lives
happy and better and complete and now
they're collecting dust unused the
exercise equipment the pet accessories
the stacks of magazines the Irish
sweater and the conch that you're that
you're holding on to and then there are
the things we could quote never discard
the items that hold wistful nostalgia
grandma's doilies dad's suit jacket
mom's jewelry that damn Irish sweater no
you aren't required to get rid of
anything but if you're stressed by the
excess then perhaps it's time to
jettison something mmm you needn't let
go of everything today just let go the
best you can yeah you know the one more
one more thing I want to add to uh
Sabrina Sean he's put that in the show
notes
it's a Bryn's question here is Bren
sounds like and this is not a judgment
this is just me dealing with the
information we have from this question
sure Bren sounds like they are trying to
get acceptance from other people Hey
look at me I've been Ireland hey I've
been to the beach I've been to this
Beach and I've got these things to prove
it in and you know someone might look at
that and go oh that's a really cool
sweater and then Bren feels good about
themselves like oh yes thank you it is a
nice sweater we all need acceptance in
some way anyone who is you know living
by themselves in the middle of nowhere
well they have chosen to live without
acceptance but they still need it in in
in in some way I'm and I'm just I'm just
you know trying to really make sure that
what I'm saying is is makes sense in a
general way we
we all newly second the caveat right
good yeah so we all need some type of
acceptance the question is is Bryn what
are you are you gaining the right
acceptance with things so you might have
this what if Brent had this amazing
collection of this amazing collection of
souvenirs and great people looked at
those souvenirs and Brynn's got a really
awesome collection of souvenirs and
brands got that approval and that
acceptance of people telling them yes
you've got an amazing collection of
souvenirs but is that are those
souvenirs is that really serving a
meaningful life I mean this is really
just my way of saying that we we need
acceptance we need people to to you know
support us in that way letting us know
that they approve of what we all need
approval in some way we just have to
make sure that we're searching for the
acceptance and the approval in a
meaningful way I think that when I think
about any of our friends like by dr.
green or Shawn or Jordan or Jessica or
our partners or my friend Nate green is
going to be in town this weekend and our
friend Shawn mihalick is gonna be here
this weekend and we accept them not
because of any of the things that they
own and they accept us not because of
like oh wow you've I really like your
apartment or I like your car or yeah I
really like the way you dress that's the
wrong kind of acceptance exactly we want
to accept the person for who they are
not for what they augment their life
with because if you like just the facade
of the house but there are a bunch of
termites or it's just rotting inside or
it's just torn apart inside that's the
wrong kind of acceptance you wouldn't
buy a house that has a beautiful facade
but is rotting inside yeah and the same
thing is true with the the people that
we bring into our lives you don't expect
them to be perfect no of course not but
but we do we do expect the sort of
exterior to match the interior well you
know going with that it the what I was
talking about earlier with these tools
that we have available to us in our
lives and other an extension I
yes you know if someone's out there and
their friends judge them or their
acceptance is reliant on the tools that
they have in their life well their
friends might be tools Bren I'd love to
send you a copy of our book essential
it's an essay collection with a hundred
and fifty essays about intentional
living it's twelve different chapters
twelve different areas of intentional
living and one of those areas one of
those chapters deals with stuff there's
quite a few essays it might be the
longest or second longest chapter in
there about how to appropriately let go
how to better deal with the excess stuff
that we have in our lives so Sean if you
reach out to her give her the audio book
or the book book or the eBook version of
essential essays by the minimalist and
we'd love to hear what y'all have to say
if you have a comment or a tip about
curating or collecting including advice
for any of our callers today leave us a
voicemail at four zero six two one nine
seven eight three nine you can also
email a voice memo to podcast at the
minimalists comm where our favorite
comments and tips on a future episode
and stay tuned to the end of this
episode for this week's listener
comments and tips Ryan what time is it
Josh it is time for our lightning round
where we answer questions from social
media here check this out dude I got
lightning bolts on my eyes ah gotcha
our first lightning round question is
from whom oh wait wait we're on Twitter
we're on Facebook and we're on Instagram
at the minimalists during the lightning
round so Ryan and I H do our best to
answer every question was just a short
shareable less than 140 character
response
we also put the text of these minimal
Maxim's in the show notes so you can
copy and share our pit the answers on
social media if you'd like and now you
can find all of our quotes in one place
thanks to our good friend Jessica Lynn
Williams minimal maxims comm is a place
for all of those quotes yeah man I love
seeing it's funny I'll see like someone
tweet something I said I'm like that I
really say that our first line your own
question is from Adam what are your
thoughts about collecting useful things
that will get better with age raw denim
specifically but also cast-iron pans and
leather boots
well so here's my pithy answer and let's
talk about this as the seasons pass some
things get better with age
just like your forehead and some things
rot it's important to know the
difference
amen so so I mean quite often there are
things that do get better with with age
and although again is it too precious
for me am i holding on to it because of
the wistful nostalgia or is it like like
the boots that I own it's weird they
have a bell curve they actually do get
better with age Brennan eventually they
get so worn out that I've had them
resold once or twice and and now the
love letters are starting to go and now
their worst with it worse with age and
to a point where I have to be willing to
let go even though there's a halt but
they've gotten better with age yeah they
did yeah but now they're no longer
useful time to let go I love that that
analogy man cuz it makes me think that
there you know this Adam may very well
have a nice pair of denim jeans some
great collection of you know iron pans
leather boots are these amazing objects
we have in our life are they making us
feel some are we riding on the inside
from from owning these things yeah so
yeah just to continue your metaphor
something that we're holding on to if
we're feeling discontent with it then
that is that is a signifier that
something is wrong and I know that when
I was experiencing a lot of discontent
in my life like it felt like I was
rotting inside my short answer is this
excuses to collect are plentiful focus
on curating a meaningful life and avoid
collecting excuses hmm yeah it's that's
one of our biggest collections there
because even the best excuse is still an
excuse absolutely you can tweet that one
to Sean and man we can get really good
at navigating the the waters with our
with our excuses oh my god I mean if I
allowed myself I could I could talk
myself into hanging on to everything
justify everything I could just yes I
could justify anything I could
if I buying a mansion on a forty year
mortgage yeah I'm that good at talking
myself into things right I was talking
to my doctor about this this weekend
forty year mortgage yeah I mean that's
the new thing we were talking to Chris
Hogan about it the that's the new wave
it's just like reaffirmed the new wave
reaffirms the how mortgage is a route it
comes from the word the root word of
mortgage like it means death contractors
yeah thanks guys
and so so when I could talk myself
literally into buying a mansion on a
forty year 50 year mortgage and and feel
good about it in the moment knowing that
my future self will suffer from it
significantly my future self in fact
that's one of the things that I think
about and I think I wrote this down
somewhere yeah well my future self be
proud of having owned this yeah so so if
it's that bad that Irish sweater or
whatever right or the conch shell or the
the denim boots or whatever will my
future self be proud of having owned
this yeah I look back at the house that
I built when I was 22 years old I'm
proud of the lessons that I learned
after the Fagor I'm not proud of owning
the oversized house and the suburbs in a
place I didn't even really want to live
that much but that's what I was supposed
to do yeah not because I thought I would
support what I thought I was supposed to
because it's what I thought everyone
else's beliefs were so I made the excuse
of well yeah I'll just put yeah I could
put zero down I can get it right now but
of course my future self which is now my
present self is not proud of that
purchase dude the the proudness man I'd
like another pithy answer I just thought
of is instead of being proud of your
material possessions be proud of your
creations yes like when I think about
there's nothing in my there's nothing I
own right now that I would be proud of
owning later yeah I mean they're the
only thing that I'll be I will be proud
of are the creations that you and I put
out into the world man
yeah and not just that with the but the
value that I can bring to whether it's a
soup kitchen or whether it's to a friend
or family member like that those
things that I am proud of yeah and it
took work to get there it's not like I
just woke up one and I'm like alright
these are the things are gonna make me
proud now like I really had to change a
lot of habits and I had to take a lot of
actions to to to get to this point but
but man it feels good to like I mean
really and truly I'm as you were saying
that ask yourself am I gonna be proud to
own this in the future I'm going through
all the items that I own in my head and
I'm like there's not one freaking thing
that I would be like I'm so glad I owned
that yeah I made my life so much I mean
I love to snowboard so like I love the
experience and I have to have a
snowboard in order to have that
experience right but but I don't care if
I'm on a on a Burton or a whatever like
I don't care the brand name of the
snowboard it is long as it works well
for you exactly and so and that's why I
was very specific about the wording
there cuz I totally agree with you like
there's no item I'm proud of owning I'm
not I have a really nice college I
really like my cows yeah
I'm not proud of owning it but well my
future self be proud of having owned it
meaning do well my future self say hey
you made the right decision yes you
spent 2 or 3 or 4 months it was longer
than that actually waiting for this
couch in him and and doing the research
and and figure out that thing really
enhance your life and did you bring it
into your life intentionally I'm proud
about proud of the decision to bring it
into your life out of the decision
absolutely what's our next question our
next question is from Beth what if my
collections are meaningful how can
someone curate a collection what are
ways to display items that have meaning
so first off here's my first pithy
answer our objects do not possess any
meaning except for the meaning we thrust
upon them
mmm so so there's no inherent meaning in
a thing and I think we need to realize
that it's so important to realize this
item is not meaningful the just like a
tool isn't inherently it's not gonna fix
your problems I mean you have to do the
fixing with the tool a tool is as good
as its user absolutely I could bludgeon
you to death with a hammer or I could
just you know hang a picture with it
right and or I could do both of you
except
about my other short answer is curation
is the deliberate collecting of that
which adds value yeah and so so these
things maybe you're asking the wrong
question what if my collections are
meaningful do your collections add value
to your life if so great or do they get
in the way of your life if so let go the
best you can absolutely my short answer
is this collecting is impulsive curation
is a skill when developing any skill you
need to practice and sometimes a mentor
so if Beth if you're having a hard time
of figuring out exactly how to display
your collection and invite someone over
who has nice aesthetics and see if they
can help you display it in a nice way if
you're having a hard time deciding on
you know what you should what you should
keep what you shouldn't keep what you
should curate find someone who is a
curator maybe maybe you got a friend or
a family member who does a good job with
their stuff at home and they have a nice
curation ask for tips but but you know
ultimately if you want to be a if you
want to have a good curation of things
it is a skill and you have to develop it
yeah
PS Ryan we have one more question is do
ya from Caesar alright is there a magic
number Marie Kondo says a collection
shouldn't be more than 30 items oh man
we all know the number is oh wait don't
don't say the number yet right do you
you know what cuz it's not 30 I got some
weird OCD thing going on right now
you got Adam Beth and Caesar ABC did you
do that on purpose
no I didn't oh that's good so I actually
have a lot to say and I'm gonna get
pretty flat flagrant on this one but if
you'd like to hear our answers to that
question about the magic number then you
can listen this week's post script
episode over at the minimalist private
podcast it's available exclusively to
our patreon supporters so if you want to
support our show and keep this podcast
100% advertisement free then head on
over to the minimalists comm slash
support in addition to our weekly
PostScript episodes the minimalist
private podcast feed includes our
monthly ask the minimalist anything
episodes on
these recordings of our live events and
the entire back catalogue of past
private episodes and once you become a
supporter you receive a personal link to
our private podcast feed so that it
plays in your normal podcast player
that's the player you listen to this
podcast to right now and as a patreon
supporter you also receive access to our
monthly livestream videos as well as
first access to tickets to all of our
live events before those tickets are
available to the general public so you
can get the best seats in the house you
can find all the details and all the
good stuff over at the minimalists comm
slash support and here is a snippet from
this week's PostScript episode
[Music]
you know what there are some collections
that add immense value to your life but
there might be 32 items in that there
might be a hundred and thirty-two items
in a thing in a collection or a
collection of 30 widgets might be 30
widgets too many and so no there isn't a
magic number that would make everything
really easy if there was a magic number
there was an appropriate amount of items
for you to own okay now it's time for
our added value portion of the show this
is where we each talk about something
that has added value to our lives
recently I have two things Ryan I just
listened to this Joe Rogan interview
with Henry Rollins and I think it's the
second time he's had Henry Rollins on
and I've I've come to the realization
that Henry Rollins is my spirit animal
no I I he is so much like me it is it is
eerie now there's like you one steroids
well maybe literally at some point
remember he's a neck and why frickin
video that was I remember like junior
high and what seeing that video that
you're talking about and I heard a black
flag right yeah and I remember late I
think it was and I remember thinking
he's got Shroff itself in the video yeah
I just remember thinking like that dude
could like flex his muscles and have his
own bulletproof vest well I think he's
60 years old now so I've seen him do
spoken word events and he'll just gonna
say you talk for two and a half hours
without a clear script but he's so good
at it but he's really into creation and
into the work and he doesn't have a lot
of friends and I realized like I'm the
same way like he's like I'm willing to
help out the people I care about like if
if Shawn calls me and says hey man I got
arrested tonight can you cut and I'm
down in Tijuana can you come help me up
but like yeah just give me three hours
I'll be down there like not a problem
I'll figure it out but if he invites me
over for dinner I'll be like
man why would you do that to me right
you don't want to come over for dinner
you know it's funny that's why it cuz I
thought about um because I had these
guys over for dinner the other night
yeah and I was yeah and I was like man I
was like I forgot to invite Josh I was
like wait no I didn't know you know me
so well you know got to invite me over
for dinner come over have a game night
game night sounds so terrible to me and
we much fun for years though so it was
episode 1150 11:55 1 1:55 on the Joe
Rogan podcast and man it I did he talked
about his he's written 27 books Wow and
you know he has all these albums he's
not as many as Collin right but no
definitely more albums in columns we
hope it'll do 200 tour stops a year and
they spoken-word things you know it's he
is like just the Machine he really
enjoys the work itself and it's almost
like it's it's the act of it's not the
completion he knows it's never gonna be
complete but it's completing that task
so he knows he can move on to the next
one and it resonated with me so much the
act of enjoying the creative process now
there between him and me is I have a
family you know I have Rebecca and we
have Ella and he doesn't have a family
and it's against my natural sort of
inclination my natural tendencies my
natural proclivities to even have a
family I never anticipated like meeting
someone like that so I'd really did
anticipate living a life like Henry
Rollins and being alone for the rest of
my life and one thing that like I I
don't like living with other people I
don't like being around people most of
the time and the other thing he talked
about was like most of his friends are
actually people he just works with
they're they're people who are like on
payroll or Commission and like for me
that's the the same thing like if I like
you enough we're gonna end up probably
working together because that's the only
because I that's what I spend my time
doing yeah there's nothing worse with
working with someone you can't get along
with dude exactly that's miserable it
reminds me of Dave Ramsey were just at
their campus but last one yeah
we're at their campus last month and
their hiring process they hire a lot
less for skills and you'll go through
sometimes 15 interviews to get to get
higher at the Dave Ramsey solutions 15
the very the fact they do a spouse
interview they interview your spouse to
make sure that you're compatible with
their values because they know that okay
it's important you have a base level of
talent but they can develop the skills
in you but they can't develop is working
well together right and so being able to
work well with other people they don't
work well with Sean or Jessica or Jordan
it's far more important we can develop
those those skills together over time we
can tweak our preferences over time but
we better be able to get along even I
don't care if you're you know you can be
Michelangelo the greatest artist of all
time but if we can't get along then what
is it if you feel like Michelangelo
didn't get along with anyone yeah I mean
I don't know but no I'm with you man
yeah and so yeah you could be four you
could yeah Brad Pitt come walk in the
room right now like great like do you
get along or not right yeah right and so
it's really important to be able to get
along with those people if you want to
work with them but for me like if I do
get along with you he'll we're probably
gonna end up working together because
that's what I do most time I work I work
almost from the time I get up to the
time I go to sleep but it doesn't feel
like work to me and this I mean there
was the drudgery of administrative stuff
it's not work so much as its creation
right and there's still drudgery of the
creation as well but I really enjoy the
act of of creating things and speaking
of creating things and rebell one of our
favorite artists he was on our podcast
the Indianapolis event whatever that one
was I'm Brady five maybe he opened up
for us he did you know a set there yeah
he came on the added-value it's like one
of my favorite favorite shows man that's
definitely top three yeah it was so good
and he has a new song out he did a cover
of the Nazi star song fade into you and
many kids in their singles men it's well
he doesn't do that kind of thing he's an
album guy I know but he he's I really
like the song I want to cover it in a
way and it's not a cut that's gonna make
an album so he covered fade into you in
a way that is it's very and Rubel it's
not true that's
Sara Lee to the original but it is
gorgeous maybe Sean podcast Sean if we
can in this this podcast well if you're
watching it on YouTube we'll put a link
to it
I'm sure Jordan can figure out how to
put like a picture-in-picture a link or
whatever but fade into you the new cover
by and your bail will will will play you
out with that one as Bill O'Reilly would
say play it out all right all right it
myself we gonna write it yourself Ryan
what's been adding value to your to your
life renewed first off I love the way
that I'm using social media now because
it forces me to look up who I want to
pay attention to
huh and it's no offense to people that I
don't look up on a regular basis but
what I realize is like a lot of the
stuff on my feed it was just there as
like a hat tip I'm following you
yeah and I I'm just having a lot better
experience what they're doing I was
gonna like go back and I actually
started to follow us on people back and
I was like why am I doing this out it
was out of obligation
it was out of like not value but
obligation because I'm I because there
are people who mean so much to me dude
Colin right for example like he was the
first one I went to go reef alo because
he means so much and I want him to know
that he means so much to me I can do
that in better ways than just following
him on Twitter it's a pretty bad way to
show show them now Colin is actually the
first person I recommend people follow
on Twitter because I get so much value
from his his video to know I don't know
he's at column is my name on on Twitter
at Colin is my name but he shares really
useful articles that I really like but
there are other people who I like that I
don't I get less value from a friend of
ours Chris Brogan we've we've done
events with him love Christmas yes
awesome
yeah I get less value from his Twitter
account personally yeah that doesn't
mean that someone else will I mean
clearly he has way more followers than
Colin he probably has a million
followers or something but I get far
more value from Colin who has just you
know thousands of followers but because
he curates his account in a way that is
on aligned with my interests yes when I
want to find an interesting article I go
to Colin's Twitter feed yeah I will look
up Colin right now I don't always
want interesting articles to read in
fact it's overwhelming when I'm like oh
there her 10 articles I know I'm not
gonna read that I probably should read
right um but but when I want that you
know latest technology or perspective on
a social issue I mean Colin is very good
about curating a Twitter feed that well
it just has things in the news that I
normally wouldn't pick up myself because
I don't go to a million different news
sites and it's it's things that I am
interested that I would be interested in
and so you trust him to curate a fee
yeah as I share articles and stuff as
opposed to you going out and trying to
find the I'm gonna look at 30 different
websites 40 different websites right and
then I'm going to curate it myself you
can trust certain people so I'll tell
you a few of my people favorite people
to follow on Twitter Anthony Jeselnik
the comic crystally the comic who else
thought do I really enjoy Sam Harris his
articles where we just mentioned Colin
right and then Richard Florida is
another one Richard Florida is a sort of
demographer he he wrote the book the
creative class and and he writes about
cities and urbanization and and
demographics and and and how we can
shift I mean it's kind of the opposite
of that the article we read earlier but
Richard Florida he's a professor in
Toronto now but he talks about the
issues that cities face and how we can
overcome them through sort of collective
use of resources and I find a lot of
value in the stats and things that he
shares and things that he retweets so
those are I think probably the top five
people and it's nice to say the top five
people those are the things I think
about the people I think about off the
top of my head right there those are
five great people to follow on Twitter
awesome men I was I was looking at TK
Coleman's Twitter specifically and he
had this tweet and he's another awesome
person to follow him and he definitely
has he wrote you can afford to veer off
the beaten path you can afford to create
your own way you can afford to ignore a
device you don't believe in you can
afford to admit that you what you really
think and feel this
this is so this is like really hit home
for me the world is big enough to handle
you your honesty will not cause an
apocalypse and you know what dude there
is a someone mentioned how they gave me
the perspective on how there are
hoarders and they were things but we
heard other things besides physical
objects right and one of those things
are whether it's a pressure that we put
on ourselves we [ __ ] we hoard
responsibilities that's a big one man
we love to hoard responsibili we just
love to say yes to everything right I'm
so busy yeah yeah and right here man
this is to me it really it translated to
someone who is hoarding responsibilities
and who says yes to everything right
because I know that I got to a certain
point in my life where it was a tornado
of a lifestyle that I brought on myself
because I was saying yes to everything
and I was scared to say no well because
I thought my world there'd be an
apocalypse that would happen in my world
and this is just affirmation that
yeah those boulders that we picked up
those responsibilities we picked up the
pressures we pick up all those things we
pick up we absolutely can set them down
and the world is not going to end yeah
teeka coleman thanks for that dude that
was that was a great tweet and it's just
that's why I love Twitter man yeah I
mean it's such a short shareable thing
and I mean it really like I was thinking
about this tweet for like an hour after
I read it
yeah I've heard someone say that you
know tweets aren't gonna change your
life and my response to that is you're
probably using Twitter wrong if that's
the case for me I still get the most
value from Twitter compared to any other
platform it's not even not even close
and in fact I've met we met TK Coleman
he's been our podcast twice now he's
been on live in room conversations with
us he's he he's become a good friend and
we've gone out to dinner we we we've
gone to comedy clubs together and then
he moved away but uh but I look at we
moved to LA he leaves yes wait a minute
but I I and we text all the time TK and
I and I think he's a great guy but he
has a ton of really great insights and
what
I'll Twitter I don't think I would have
known that yeah so yeah he's definitely
got to follow all right let's move on to
right here right now so we talked about
what's going on in the lives of the
minimalist so last week Ryan we filmed
the final scene of our second
documentary the minimalists less is now
well we filmed the final scene that will
give us a first draft right of the film
and I really hope because the way it's
laid out it's not there aren't a bunch
of interviews with other people I don't
think we have to go out and obviously
not gonna be in oh I hope this is it - I
just know from our previous experience
with filming the documentary sometimes
you got to put in some missing pieces
but but dude that said though we've
learned a lot from that last documentary
we absolutely did I mean the last one
there was 2,000 hours of footage to
whittle down the 79 minutes talk about
curation and this time we knew we needed
4,000 hours twice as many sunset time
lapses no and so we I think Matt and I
spent four or five hours in my home and
then also at the store we did this
little widget thing there's this this
monologue that I have in the new
documentary about about the true cost of
only thing the actual cost of an item
yeah going way beyond the actual price
tag within we won the show we had this
widget and I'm not going to give it away
with the widget is exactly but what it
really takes to own a thing goes way
beyond the price tag and so that was the
final scene we had to film it's not the
final scene in the documentary it's
outside of chronological order but
hopefully this will be about 60 to 70
minute a lot of curation has gone gone
as we've been working on it for about
the last year the next step is the
soundtrack I have a meeting with Drew
and Nate this week they formed the band
we for the first the soundtrack to our
first documentary and they're getting
the band back together
literally and who knows Jordan we might
drag you out to to Salt Lake City to go
to the studio to film some of the the
making of the the soundtrack the score
for this film they're super excited
about it
and I can't wait to see what they put
together i zoom through
is just an innate is a great producer is
a grammy-nominated producer drew is one
of the most talented musicians his voice
is an instrument in and of itself and he
just knows how to compose something that
that is a a soundscape of simplicity any
time drew makes new music man I'm always
having yeah yeah I mean Shawn and I were
driving around LA last week and the one
CD I haves parler Hawk Drew's band and
the fifth saw on their song called save
me mm-hmm and it's aggressively simple
and I love the story behind that yeah
and and it's it's curation right yeah
because it was actually the most complex
song on that album which is by the way
the perfect album we were at a Dave
Ramsey's studio and afterward they they
did a quick lightning round Q&A with us
that if you're on a desert island what's
the one album you bring with you and for
me it's no question it's parler Hawks
album like it's it's the most complete
sort of perfect album to me and I don't
know if you could even find this I
probably shouldn't be recommending it
you might find a CD on eBay or something
I think I get I think it's on identity
might or Spotify one of the two because
I've got his albums yeah yeah and so
such a such a great album and that song
saved me is so stripped down there's
like some distorted electric guitar
there's very slight acoustic guitar
there's some banjo some feedback
happenin yeah and and on top of that
there was drums there were string didn't
easily over work or something yeah they
did an orchestra yeah and they stripped
it all away and it's just him and his
voice singing saved me saved me and and
like it is it's you can tell that it's
the most complete song because of the
curation the empty spaces between notes
are just as important if not more
important than the notes themselves and
that is the whole point of this entire
episode great album yeah so we're
working on the soundtrack for that now I
really hope the documentary is out by
end of the year stay tuned if you're
email lists you'll be the first to know
about news updates LeMat said he was
gonna have it up by Black Friday right
that would be great and and so hopefully
we got a it's not really up to to us and
Matt we're we're gonna figure out where
no pressure Matt the home is going to be
but now the people expect it well matt
has about about six days left on the
documentary so yeah he's he's working
vigorously on on the edits at this point
and he and I have been communicating a
lot so he literally has six days left
until he has to give it to Nate Andrew
so yes we're right around the corner
there but hopefully we'll have it out by
end of the year and ideally Black Friday
would be great depending on where it
ends up finally where its final home
will be all right also uh-oh if we have
time what what's the time looking like
what give us a recap of your health okay
very high level just do high low time to
go into every single detail yes so so
what have you let's make this an
interview what if you added back into
your diet so you right you were right up
to a certain point you were doing meat
you were doing greens you were doing
oils and a little bit of dark chocolate
yep and coffee and some coffee and now
is that those are the five morning
coffee beans you were drinking coffee
yeah it's not there yeah I was chewing
the collar I think you like it do you
like it that strong yeah so what what
things have you added tried to adding
back into your diet a bunch of things
one at a time okay what's so light like
I've just been experimenting so I had I
guess you'd call it a cheat day the
first week of August I had like the
salad from Takaya it's like my favorite
Mexican place and you know I and what's
got in there it had some strawberries
which I actually didn't eat the
strawberries but I just don't feel like
I haven't been eating fruit at all
there's a little bit corn there was no
quinoa there was a few almonds okay so
you know it's yep and man my home stunk
that evening did you very flatulent yeah
but like but but you know earth stinky
why right and so isn't that funny dude
look when I cleaned up my diet uh-huh
like my [ __ ] literally doesn't stink
anymore
all right that's that side that's the
weird thing and so I realized that like
a lot of the extra things that the extra
fibers are not good for me to bring back
in yet that's not saying that I won't in
the future I'm just saying right now
this modified carnivore diet there are
certain fibers I shouldn't bring back
into my life there was also Palmer
granite seeds were in there that could
have been part of the problem as well a
few days later I tried a handful of
mixed nuts mm-hmm and they do not agree
with me oh that's one of the culprits
eggs and mixed nuts I've realized I
don't I prime I have a slight egg
allergy because they destroy me last
time I tried eggs was last month and I
was down for a day you're talking about
talking AB rain fog no I am talking
brain okay so yeah I guess expound on
when you say it destroys you what does
that mean so the nuts are both I start
to feel kind of tired lethargic but then
also I had some gut issues around eating
those nuts so mmm the eggs there were no
gut issues but it was like oh I'm so
tired and my I didn't have brain fog so
much is like I felt exhausted after
eating the eggs with the nuts it was a
mixture of both so I've realized okay no
more nuts in my life right Brussels
sprouts I tried those one day and they
just make me a little bit gassy and I
may be a little slight digestion problem
but but I didn't feel really bad on
those and then last weekend I had a
piece of avocado toast on sourdough
bread from our favorite place PCP or
favorite local breakfast spot nice and
I'm sure it tasted awesome
it was it was delicious and it made me
feel I was fine I did I had no digestion
issues which shocked the hell out of me
that is pretty shocking because it has
gluten in it and the avocado I was
unsure about mm-hmm but the next morning
I woke up with achy joints and really
that night I had crazy achy joints oh do
inflammation yeah gluten causes
inflammation it's not just a gluten I
think it's the the fiber as well I think
because fiber in the avocado no no I
mean bread is you know Brad is less 500
and so I think and the carbohydrates
just the the the the carbohydrates in
general fast burning carbs all court no
no all carbs I call really a certain
amount of inflammation and so think
about my diet those five things there's
there are functionally no carbs in there
very little on the greens but there's no
car the truck was hit the most carbs no
that's all fat man 100% dark chocolate
is fat so okay so there are carbs that
doesn't that yeah so there there is a
difference between we are talking about
a difference between carbs here where
Donna well I what the statement I made
was fast burning carbs or what causes
the inflammation now you're saying all
carbs yes except for chocolate carbs I'm
saying chocolate doesn't really have
more chocolate carbs it 100% dark
chocolate has very few if they
twenty-eight of 25 per bar 25 grams I
mean 1 square of dark chocolate and oh I
see you're not you're not doing like a
quarter of a but you're not doing one
serving no you're doing less than a
serving yes oh yes you okay I see as
opposed to having a sweet potato or I
see yes one small serving of a chocolate
yeah you're gonna get few carbs and less
than one serving of a piece of chocolate
yeah I said 100% dark chocolate is
mostly fat and so so when I look at at
the diet that I'm eating right now it's
mostly protein and greens very few green
or very few carbs in the greens even
though they are a carbohydrate use the
net amount you'd have to eat yeah a
table the size of romaine lettuce to get
a considerable amount of carbohydrates
from it right gotcha
and so I've found the reason I've so
less inflamed over the course of the
last month and a half is because I
haven't brought those carbs into my life
and when I do bring them in man I got
all this joint pain it came back within
the same day well and my knees were
hurting my ankles were hurting I've
heard other people who have gotten off
of gluten because specifically because
of the inflammation that it caused yes
it was nothing else but inflammation it
wasn't digestion all it wasn't brain fog
it was just they noticed that when they
eat gluten yes their their joints hurt a
little bit more cakey and and it's
processed carbs in general so Brad
be a processed carb right and so but I
think it extends further and I'm still
playing with it with my own body hmm but
but I know who does eventually I might
bring sweet potatoes or something back
in just to test I the nice thing about
this diet now is I've refined it and
I've stuck to it and I feel really good
on it I can bring one thing in once or
twice a week and I I can see how that
feels I can bring a sweet potato in next
week and say all right how do I feel
after eating it Sal it's an elimination
diet and it's yes it works really well
so what are you what are your foods that
you eat now what's the list is the solos
5 I mean come and I I feel pretty good
about Brussels sprouts at this point
okay you've got a sixth yeah I mean
those regularly but I mean those other
things all those other things still
everyday yeah and I feel really good
about the diet still so awesome those
five things that's where I'm at right
now stay tuned for more health updates
we'll keep you posted here and if you
want to comment on this episode the best
best place to do that youtube.com slash
the minimalists this is episode 146 is
that what today is you just go there you
can leave a comment you can interact
with other commenters I'd love to hear
what you have to say about curation or
you obviously you can call in as well
other stuff going on at YouTube for us
right now
on Mondays this podcast episode comes
out a day before the audio so if you
want to check this out early a full day
early you can watch us over on youtube
these episodes come out and then on
Tuesdays we do the pre-roll episodes
like we did today 5-10 minutes of show
prep and also maybe answering some
questions from the audience they're live
episodes but you can also check out the
video after it's posted as well so you
can check it out live it's sort of the
behind-the-scenes aspects of the podcast
every Wednesday we're doing living room
conversations we got a few coming out
with Anthony O'Neil chris hogan and
rachel cruz and then we're gonna do some
other living room conversations you just
move so we should do some living room
conversations which you're all unpacked
living room conversation
nailed it yeah man Wow
I'm gonna buy like I'm gonna buy like a
snifter a bottle of brandy and then as
we have the living room conversations
what do you think Jordan yeah yeah I'm
looking forward to seeing that Jordan
made a new intro video for the living
room conversations we're working on some
other videos one of my favorite things
and I think I figure out why this is one
of my favorites Ryan we're doing quickie
episodes now so what we do is we extract
the little bits from our podcast or
little bits from our live at live events
two minutes to 15-minute excerpt wait a
minute did you make these specifically
for the gentleman who is asking for two
minute podcast no I gave him a solution
but this actually is a good solution for
someone like that well it is I realize
why so they're actually not excerpts
they're they're standalone snippets but
they're not even snippets they they are
standalone creations you can get value
from this thing without needing to
listen to a slide yeah yeah and so
they're their own creation you know it's
not like well and now you have to listen
to the full extended no here's one
thing's gonna add value I realized what
I get so much value from it because that
is how I use youtube quite often I'll
see a Joe Rogan snippet or a Joe Budden
snippet or someone else named Joe who
has a podcast I will find that these
little quickie episodes that there are
these full pieces of it's like Joe Rogan
talks about why Shaquille O'Neal would
be good at in an a and you're like okay
that's one it's a sham to me well he
could have I wants yeah actually he
waited way too much I think I think oh
yeah there's a limit yeah how big you
265 yeah they're super heavyweight but
there's no one in the division so for
above 265 there's like three people
though there's there's literally no one
oh I see there's a weight class super
heavy I mean I think he was probably
about three thirty when well he'd be the
super heavyweight champion he still is
it's just him that's really but you rock
you put on some weight and
get her ass kicked yeah no thanks yeah I
think I'll pass but these quickie
episodes eventually we're gonna try to
get to we're gonna get a few of these
out a week right now we've already put
out a few at this point so you can find
those on our YouTube channel and
eventually well maybe have one of those
a day we're also working on a tour recap
vlog monthly vlog called live a
meaningful life people often ask us
what's the well what's the average day
of a minimalist we don't have a good
answer to that but here's an ideal month
of a minimalist what does it mate what
is what's included in living a
meaningful life and man I've been
struggling with this yeah the last week
or so we've been recording some things
for for Jordan and like Bex and I were
hanging out went to the Russian
bathhouse this weekend and went to this
Art Walk up in Northeast LA in Highland
Park and Eagle Ridge or Eagle Rock and
and we were you I found myself like okay
now I have to record something for
Jordan so hey Jordan here's a video of
us at the Art Walk or hey Jordan here's
me walking around last night preparing
for our podcast and it's trying to give
people an inside look at what does it
mean to live in meaningful life and some
of that's gonna be a lot of the boring
things that I do like get up early in
the morning and write but Jordan will
find a way to edit it and making it make
it at least somewhat interesting also
we're gonna do some minimalism tips on
YouTube we're gonna do some home tours
eventually of our homes and some other
YouTube shows as well you can find all
of that at our youtube channel
youtube.com slash the minimalist and if
you want all of our podcast notes you
always hear me talk to podcast Sean and
say hey put that in the show notes
podcast Sean then just sign up for our
email list over at the minimalists com
you go there you type you in your email
address at the top we'll never send you
any spam because that stuff is gross and
promise
speaking of curation if you want to find
a really well curated website and a well
curated Instagram account to follow our
side project is called minimalism life
the website is minimalism dot life and
the Instagram handle is at minimalism
life our friend Karl and our friend
Alberto work with us to bring you the
best of minimalist well-being minimalist
travel
and minimalist design all in one place
you can find that at minimalism dot life
Ryan you got anything else for us yeah
man I got some voicemail comments and
tips from our listeners check them out
hi guys I'm Brittany originally from
Montana and now living in New York I
wanted to call because you guys speak a
lot about intention well I believe that
intention is important when buying I
also think we should use intention when
we're decluttering for example I'm a
huge movie fan and recently got rid of
over 60 DVDs instead of dropping them
off at the thrift store to be sold I
donated them all to my local library
like so my boyfriend was finally ready
to give up his xbox so we found a local
shelter that frequently has children and
we donated the games and consoles to
them while it does create a few extra
trips your things can really create
value for someone else if you let them
hey this is Jane in Los Angeles I just
had a tip for cat from the diet EMS owed
I used to have a lot of trouble making
decisions too and now whenever I go out
to eat and I'm looking at a menu I get
five seconds to pick and making quick
fast decisions has helped me get better
and more comfortable with making
decisions in other parts of my life
hahaha this is Molly from Michelin and I
had thoughts that I wanted to share
about some old episodes but I didn't
listening to the first is about a
mechanical engineering student who was
worried about the way that his work and
he graduated might contribute to issues
of unneeded consumption and too much
stuff in the world what I wanted to say
that my husband is in a chemical
engineer but he's mechanical engineer in
buildings so he designs complex building
systems all of the heating ventilation
air conditioning plumbing as they say
everything that sucks and blows in the
in these buildings and that allows
buildings to new buildings to use less
energy and allows people to reuse old
buildings that they might not otherwise
have been able to keep in use and would
otherwise have had to tear down if they
couldn't figure out some kind of special
way to to get around having a building
that wasn't designed to have
air-conditioning for example so that's a
way that this student could actually go
into engineering and have a positive
impact on the environment and really
knowing impact on consumption so the
second thing is about souvenirs and what
we do is we will buy things on trips
that aren't stereotypical souvenirs
they're more everyday type items so for
example on our honeymoon in Ireland my
husband bought a tweed jacket and it's
great he wears it in the fall he wears
it in the spring it's a perfect jacket
for that time when it's just a little
too cold for a sport coat
but it's too warm for big p-code big
puffy down coat and it really fits a
spot in his wardrobe and he would the
buy something there
that's unusual not the kind of thing you
would get here and then every time he
worth it it reminds a mom our club but
it's not just some chachi all right Joe
that's it for this episode if you have a
question for the minimalists give us a
call for zero six two one nine seven
eight three nine you can also email a
voice memo to podcast at the minimalists
comm we're especially looking for
questions about discipline spouses and
preferences now this preferences one is
interesting because we're going to be
taking this we both know what our
myers-briggs is you're an ENFP I'm an
INTJ I also border ISTJ
and we're gonna be talking about
personalities and how those different
personalities interact with each other
but there's a lot of people been talking
about this this other personality test
the Enneagram which a lot of
professionals have been using now and
just like a newer myers-briggs yes yeah
yeah an updated personality test exactly
the kids are using and I don't put too
much weight into any of these these
tests I'm gonna put me in a box
I'm an INTJ so I have to behave this way
in fact it's the opposite for me I
learned more about myself so I can learn
I can compensate for my failures and I
can also strengthen my strain so I could
take the best parts of me forward and
then I can also find a way to figure out
what are my weaknesses how can I deal
with the challenges in my life and my
friend Adam down in Tennessee we when we
met with him last month when we were on
tour he was talking about the Enneagram
and how he had learned about how he
handles conflict and he's been able to
adjust that differently and so I took
the intagram this this month and I know
you're gonna take it yeah I got my
partner Becks taking it as well I like
the I like these tests because it helps
me understand people better yeah yeah it
helps me understand myself better but in
all actuality like what I'm talking to
someone else like if I know I'm dealing
with an introvert versus an extrovert
like I'm not
I'm not going I'm gonna like tone it
down a little bit maybe how to respect
them I am NOT going to like be in their
face I'm not gonna ask him over for
dinner like I am going to I am going to
treat them the way that they want to be
treated yes and it doesn't mean that
they're right or wrong it's just they
have certain preferences and if I know
someone's preferences it allows me to
foster a better relationship
the nice thing about the personality
test is you don't take it for you you
take it for other people quite often
yeah because you can better understand
yourself you can better understand how
you can interact more appropriately in
certain situations so we're gonna take
out our part is gonna take it I know
Jordan and Jess are talking about taking
it as well so we will have a way to
figure out how do we best interact with
the people around us so that we can
communicate with them better I can how
can I make my relationships with other
people better so we're not just
accepting them but we're appreciating
them for who they are yeah so yeah if
you have questions about preferences or
personalities or discipline or spouses
you have questions about any of those
they'll make it to the top of the list
just say when you call in hey my
questions about discipline or my
question is about spouses or my
questions about preferences or
personality the same thing we're thinkin
ality or preferences then we'll move
either to the front of a line there or a
question about anything else you can
give us a call and if you all leave here
with today with just one message we hope
it's this love people and use things
because the opposite never works thanks
for listening y'all we'll see you next
time minimus